[Music]
welcome back everyone so we've been
talking about compressed sensing and how
you can get away with many many fewer
measurements than you would normally
think you could you could get away with
if those measurements have an aspect of
randomness to them and so I'm going to
illustrate this on a really fun example
which is kind of a toy example of an
audio signal in Python okay so what
we're going to do is we're gonna create
a signal that is essentially a signal in
time so some audio signal in time that
is very very sparse in Fourier in fact
it's going to be a two-tone audio signal
that is going to be created by taking
the sum of a ninety-seven Hertz cosine
wave and a 777 Hertz cosine wave so this
the signal is ultra simple in the time
domain it's just gonna look like a sum
of two cosine waves and in the Fourier
domain it's going to basically just have
two power
peaks at ninety seven and seven hundred
and seventy seven Hertz okay very very
sparse this is a toy problem that
illustrates what an audio signal
reconstruction problem would look like
okay and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna create a very high resolution
version of that signal at a sampling
rate of 4096 Hertz or 4096 samples per
per second okay and then what we're
gonna do is we're going to massively
massively down sample that that signal
to get why but we're going to do it
randomly okay so this is super important
and I'm gonna walk through this a little
bit but the basic idea here is that the
the Shannon Nyquist sampling theorem
would say that if I want to recover this
very high frequency component that 777
Hertz component of my signal there's no
way I could do that if I sample my
system at a rate of like 128 Hertz or
something really low low frequency okay
so low frequency sampling if I sample it
low frequency and I'm just gonna draw a
picture here it says really simple to
understand if I have something really
really high frequency like this but I
sampled this thing
really infrequently then there's no way
you can tell that this high-frequency
stuff is happening you're going to think
that this signal is only that one
low-frequency sine wave okay and so that
that's kind of the heart of this Shane
and Nyquist sampling theorem I'm gonna
do a whole video on Shannon Nyquist and
information theory and kind of
traditional signal processing but before
compressed sensing kind of before this
turned that on its head but the basic
idea is that if this signal has really
really high frequency components and I
sample too slowly there's no hope of
picking this up okay and I want to say
it's you have to sample at like half of
the frequency so that you can pick kind
of these peak to peak variations okay
but I'll do a whole a whole video on
that so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna sample at an average sampling rate
of 128 Hertz which we know from Shannon
Nyquist should not work at all we should
completely fail to reconstruct the low
and high frequency components of this
but the catch with compressed sensing
the reason you can beat Nyquist here is
because this why or rather this theta is
random okay so these Y points are not
uniformly sampled in time they are
randomly sampled in time and that makes
a big difference so if I randomly sample
this in time it's absolutely true that
on average my sampling rates going to be
way too low so on average I'm going to
get these points that are really far
apart but on average I'm also going to
get points that are really close to each
other sometimes so I will get a lot I
will get some points that are right next
to each other if I randomly sample and
so I'll get all kinds of points some of
them close some of them far some of them
in between and the second piece of
information about this random sampling
is I assume that even though my average
sampling rates very low 128 Hertz I'm
assuming that I have my sampling on a
very very fine clock so I know exactly
when that sampling occurred so I know
exactly when
this sample occurred in time at that
very very high resolution o'clock all
right so I know my the resolution of
when my sample occurred to a resolution
of 4096 per unit time okay that's really
important so you need to have your
random measurements so that sometimes
you get points closer or farther away
from each other so you're exploring kind
of all of the frequency space possible
and you also need to have these
measurements on a really precise clock
so even if on average it's low low
sampling rate I know very precisely when
each of those samples occurred that's
the setup we have here okay
so we're assuming that we have an
average sampling rate of 128 but we know
very precisely when their sample okay
good and so what we're gonna do is to
get this random sample we're gonna run
this this kind of line here to get these
these random permutation vector so we're
gonna just randomly pull indices from
this 4096 high fidelity signal that's
going to give me these kind of yellow
points here good and I'm just gonna plot
them and I'm not running this in real
time because this is a little bit slow
but you can run this at home you can
download all this code from data book
you w.com
we have the code in Python in MATLAB
okay and there's a link in the in the
comments okay good so here I'm just
plotting some stuff and what you see
here on the left this is the actual time
series I've zoomed in a little bit that
looks a lot like what I have here I had
this kind of to frequency you know I've
got low frequency stuff and then I've
got this ultra high frequency stuff and
these red X's are my random sampling
points at an average of 128 Hertz so I
have 128 measurements per second but
they can be anywhere randomly in that
signal so you'll notice here I've got a
bunch of points kind of bunched up that
means I'm getting some points really
close together other points very far
apart I measure very little in this
region here okay this kind of makes
sense if your signal sparse and doesn't
have that much information I really only
need to sample a few regions very very
fast to get the high frequency stuff
and then the other stuff I'll get with
the low frequency kind of these these
spread out points so I don't need to
measure you know every region at full
4096 sampling rate because I'm gonna get
that information from these points here
kind of at least that's that gives you a
gut feeling for how this might work and
then here's the power spectrum you see
that there are two peaks because the two
tone wave and now we can actually solve
for this problem using we can solve this
compress sensing problem we can solve
for the s that has the minimum one norm
meaning it'll be this Parsis s that
satisfies that's consistent with those
128 measurements okay and we're gonna do
it here using this Coast amp code which
is compressive sampling with matching
pursuit this is a really really cool
algorithm if you want to read more about
this this is a greedy algorithm matching
pursuit and it's a really fast and
accurate way of solving these problems
it works especially well if s is really
really sparse so if we're very sparse
problems this is faster than some of the
other techniques I might show you like
CVX and I'll probably have a whole video
on greedy methods later okay but if you
want to read about this you can read
about it in our book you can read about
this in papers by Joel trop and others
really cool stuff okay so this has run
it's fine the sparse solution s and then
I can inverse Fourier transform that to
see what the original signal was that's
consistent with those measurements and
when you do that you find the red points
down here is the inferred sparse vector
s this is the power spectrum of the
inferred sparse vector and then when you
inverse it's actually not just a Fourier
transform it's an inverse cosine
transform because I'm using a discrete
cosine transform you get a signal that
very faithfully reproduces the high
resolution white signal up here okay so
this is not magic but it is super cool
from these red you know non uniformly
randomly spaced points that have an
average sampling rate that should be far
too low for this high frequency data
with compressed sensing you're able to
figure out what those
high-frequency components are an inverse
Fourier transform to find to find your
solution so I think this is really
really interesting and for me the proof
is in the pudding you can talk all day
long about the math of high dimensional
vectors and geometry and whatnot but
until you actually try it out on an
example like this and see it working
it's hard to really place that math in
an applied setting so for me I think
this is really important to understand
what's happening in compress sensing
okay now there are a few things I want
to point out to you yeah so first of all
all of this code is on our book website
data book UW comm and again if you like
this material if you think this is
useful please hit like and subscribe and
hit the bell write a comment I almost
always make small typos or don't explain
things so I can you know help you kind
of flush that out in the comments so
some things I want to point out here and
this is all most homework for you at
home this example of beating the Nyquist
sampling frequency I think is really
compelling because why has an average
sampling rate of 128 Hertz now what I
would like you to do is run through this
exact same example but instead of
picking these red points at random like
I did here I want you to pick them
uniformly downsampled to 128 Hertz okay
so my original signal is 4096 I want you
to down sample that to 128 Hertz and
that means you basically measure only
every every 32 entries you only measure
every 32 entries okay so you measure the
first one the 33rd and so on and so
forth that will down sample this to 128
Hertz signal and then I want you to run
through the exact same code in fact I
want you to try to run any optimization
you possibly can to find an S that is
consistent with those hundred and twenty
eight measurements and my strong
suspicion is because I've done this a
lot for this particular problem is that
if if you use
downsampling you will absolutely get the
wrong sparsity pattern and the wrong
signal with uniform down sampling you
won't be able to get this high frequency
phenomenon because of the Shannon
Nyquist theorem okay and so I think
that'll be really really helpful for you
at home to convince yourself that what's
happening here
really does depend on the randomness of
the sampling and knowing precisely when
those samples occurred in time because
when you do kind of a naive uniform down
sampling all of this will break down and
that's relatively simple for you to code
up and try out okay so I really hope
you've enjoyed this I hope this makes us
a little bit more concrete again if you
have any questions if there's anything
you want to know about just you know ask
me and I'll try to get to it with with
you know a follow up comment or videos
when I have time so really excited to
show you kind of the next round of what
you can do with sparsity all right thank
you